El 20 de octubre de 2011, el dirigente
libio Muamar el Gadafi fue capturado y
asesinado. Y ya os digo que no fue ejecutado
precisamente de una forma muy civilizada Si
se lo merecía o no, eso ya os lo dejo a vosotros.
El caso es que la muerte de Gadafi supuso el fin
a casi 42 años de férreo gobierno. En 2011
Libia cambió, probablemente, para siempre.
El problema es que ese cambio no deje una
situación precisamente halagüeña. Y desde
entonces, para colmo, todo ha ido de mal en peor:
(Según la ONU el riesgo para la estabilidad
de Libia se incrementa tras los
mortíferos enfrentamientos entre
milicias y la agitación en Níger y Sudán. AP)
(Los supervivientes de las inundaciones de
Libia se enfrentan al trauma. Al menos 4000
personas habrían muerto cuando la tormenta
azotó Derna. Naciones Unidas)
(Tras la inundación de Libia,
las armas sin detonar suponen
un nuevo riesgo. Aljazeera)
Durante la primera semana de septiembre, la
Tormenta Daniel paso por el Mediterráneo,
y provocó unas inundaciones inmensas en Libia.
Las víctimas mortales se contaron por miles.
Claro que esta es solo la última de
las catástrofes y calamidades que
están sufriendo los libios en los
últimos años. La caída del régimen
de Gadafi provocó una segunda
guerra civil y un enorme caos.
Pero, ¿qué pasó exactamente tras la caída
de Gadafi? ¿Por qué Libia acabó sumida
en el caos más profundo? ¿Podrá este
país recuperarse en los próximos años?
Pues… Gasolina y arranquemos
Queridos amigos y amigas, a veces la historia
puede ser mucho más repetitiva de lo que podemos
llegar a imaginar, y para muestra, un botón.
El 4 de mayo de 1980, Josip Broz Tito, el
líder indiscutido de la otrora gran Yugoslavia,
pasó a mejor vida. Con su muerte se
desencadenaron un montón de tensiones
étnicas y políticas en los Balcanes, que
terminaron como el rosario de la Aurora,
La desaparición de Tito trajo consigo
la desintegración de Yugoslavia y un
montón de conflictos y sangrientas guerras.
Pero un momento, ¿no se supone que este era un
video sobre Libia? Pues sí, lo es – tranquilos
que no se nos ha ido la cabeza-. El caso es
que el derrocamiento y el asesinato de Gadafi,
amo y señor de la Libia contemporánea,
dio paso a un escenario muy similar:
Y es que veréis Libia es un país
compleJo. Está compuesto socialmente
por múltiples facciones de distintas tribus
y etnias. Hablamos de más 30 tribus y clanes
familiares que históricamente han tenido
mucho peso en la política de este país.
Durante las últimas cinco décadas lo que todos
estos grupos tuvieron en común fue, por un lado,
el sistema de mano dura que regía en el país y por
otro, el enorme aparato de favores, privilegios
y populismo petrolero que dirigía Gadafi. Ya
sabéis, la política del palo y la zanahoria.
Pero cuándo Gadafi cayó, toda esa especie de
estabilidad y armonía pagada con el dinero
del petróleo desapareció. No se produjo ninguna
transición, sino que el país se sumió en el más
completo caos. Y eso puede explicarse por esto:
C1 ("Las tribus y sectas que componen estos
Estados de carácter artificial se han mantenido
unidas durante mucho tiempo gracias al puño de
hierro de las potencias coloniales, los reyes
o los dictadores militares. Estos estados no
tienen verdaderos "ciudadanos" en el sentido
moderno. Las rotaciones democráticas en el
poder son imposibles porque cada tribu vive
bajo el lema "gobernar o morir": o mi tribu
o secta está en el poder o estamos muertos".
Thomas L. Friedman, escritor estadounidense,
tres veces ganador del Premio Pulitzer.)
Pero, ¿qué ocurrió exactamente tras la caída
del régimen de gran líder del socialismo
árabe? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T1 (DEL DESPEGUE EXITOSO AL ATERRIZAJE FORZOSO)
En el año 2011 estalló en Túnez la primavera
árabe, un proceso de protesta política
que rápidamente se extendió por todo el
norte de África y partes de Oriente
Medio. Libia no fue una excepción.
De repente se desataron grandes manifestaciones
y protestas contra el gobierno. Un movimiento que
terminó convertido en una auténtica guerra civil.
El 26 de febrero El 26 de febrero de 2011,
el Consejo de Seguridad de las Naciones Unidas
aprobó congelar los bienes a los jerarcas del
gobierno libio, y también declaró un embargo de
armas sobre el país. Más tarde, el 17 de marzo,
se aprobó también el establecimiento de
una “zona de exclusión aérea de vuelos”,
para proteger supuestamente a los civiles de
las zonas rebeldes de los ataques aéreos que
pudiera llevar a cabo el ejército libio.
Estas dos resoluciones fueron impulsadas
por Francia y Reino Unido, pero ni Rusia
ni China vetaron la iniciativa. Es decir,
que todo el mundo se volvió contra Gadafi.
Y de hecho, poco después fue la propia OTAN
intervino en este conflicto para aniquilar las
capacidades militares del régimen de Trípoli.
Al final, como ya os hemos contado, el
régimen cayó y en octubre de ese mismo
año el propio Gadafi terminó siendo
capturado, torturado y ejecutado.
Libia pasó a estar dirigida por el llamado
Consejo Nacional de Transición. Este órgano tuvo
el control durante 10 meses. Su misión era clara:
estabilizar el país y organizar unas elecciones
que abrieran paso a una nueva etapa democrática.
C2 (“Libia es un Estado democrático independiente
en el que el pueblo es la fuente de los poderes.
La ciudad de Trípoli será la capital del Estado.
El Islam es la Religión del Estado y la principal
fuente de legislación es la Jurisprudencia
Islámica (Shari'a). El Estado garantizará a
los no musulmanes la libertad de practicar
ritos religiosos. El árabe es su lengua oficial.
El Estado garantizará los derechos culturales de
todos los componentes de la sociedad libia y sus
lenguas se considerarán nacionales". Declaración
constitucional del Consejo Nacional de Transición)
El consejo cumplió y en julio del 2012 se
celebraron elecciones para escoger el
Congreso Nacional, el cual luego tendría
la misión de elegir a un primer ministro y
poner en marcha un proceso constituyente.
En esas elecciones participaron el
61,5% de los libios con derecho a
voto. En aquel momento todo pintaba bien,
el panorama era razonablemente prometedor:
Sí, había mucha tensión, pero en menos de un
año el país había sido capaz de organizar unas
elecciones nacionales y formar un gobierno. Sin
embargo, amigos, el optimismo duró tanto como
un helado en el desierto, nunca mejor dicho.
(En las elecciones parlamentarias de Libia en
2012 se utilizó un sistema conocido como el “Voto
único no transferible". Esto quiere decir que los
votantes tenían un solo voto que podían emitir
por un candidato individual en sus distritos,
eso es todo, nada de candidatos nacionales.
Lo que provocó una elección masiva de perfiles
independientes. El problema es que esto fraccionó
al congreso en múltiples monobloques, limitando la
posibilidad de crear y sostener mayorías estables.
Para colmo, comenzaron a proliferar todo tipo de
facciones islamistas radicales como el ISIS
que vieron la oportunidad de aprovechar el
desgobierno para ganar territorio.
Pese a todo, en 2014 se celebraron
nuevas elecciones. Pero en aquellos
comicios la participación ya fue solo
del 18%... Y poco después todo se rompió.
Una facción de los antiguos miembros del
Congreso Nacional se negaron a reconocer los
resultados y establecieron un gobierno paralelo en
Trípoli. Fue el llamado Gobierno de la Salvación
Nacional. Al mismo tiempo, el Congreso recién
elegido formaron su propio gobierno en Tobruk,
una ciudad libia que es fronteriza con Egipto.)
Por supuesto, la existencia de dos gobiernos
paralelos fue la gota que colmó el vaso. La
división se extendió a las fuerzas armadas y el
país acabó sumergido en una segunda guerra civil.
Y, amigos, si a la lucha interna entre
los libios, le sumamos el auge del Estado
islámico, la formación de milicias locales
autónomas, como los Tuareg o los Toubou,
y la proliferación de intereses sirios, rusos,
egipcios y turcos, Libia acabó convertida
en una especie de todos contra todos.
Para el año 2015, tal y como podéis ver,
el mapa de este país era el tablero de uno
de esos puzzles que nadie sabe como demonios
montar. Un puzzle compuesto por diferentes
gobiernos, tribus y grupos yihadistas.
En resumen, que la existencia de una
Libia unida parecía cosa del pasado.
Y, por supuesto, todos estos enfrentamientos
tuvieron también consecuencias para el mayor
negocio de este país: el oro negro con burbujas.
Libia tiene una de las 10 mayores reservas de
petróleo convencional del mundo, y hasta
que estalló la primavera árabe su nivel
de producción estaba creciendo progresivamente.
Sin embargo, a partir de entonces todo cambió.
Cómo veis, la producción se hundió un
75% en 2014, 2015 y 20116. Y aunque
luego se ha recuperado, sigue un 30%
por debajo de sus niveles del año 2010.
C3 (“Tenía más fe en que los europeos, dada
la proximidad de Libia, se implicaran en el
proceso de transición [...] El grado de
división tribal en Libia era mayor de lo
que esperaban nuestros analistas. Y nuestra
capacidad para tener allí cualquier tipo de
estructura con la que pudiéramos interactuar y
empezar a formar y a proporcionar recursos se
vino abajo muy rápidamente". Barack Obama en 2016)
En cualquier caso, en diciembre del 2015, se firmó
el “Acuerdo Político Libio”, un acuerdo promovido
por el Consejo de Seguridad de las Naciones Unidas
que estableció una mesa de diálogo entre
las diferentes facciones políticas del país.
Esto sirvió para poner en marcha un proceso
de paz y, finalmente, en 2020, la mayor parte
de bandos enfrentados logró acordar un alto
el fuego y establecer una agenda electoral.
El nuevo gobierno está compuesto por un
Consejo Presidencial, conducido hasta la
fecha por Mohamed Menfi, y un primer ministro,
Abdul Hamid Dbeibé. Ambos están en funciones
desde febrero y marzo de 2021, respectivamente.
Su misión era preparar el terreno para organizar
nuevas elecciones… Algo que no han hecho.
Y la pregunta es, ¿por qué no se han
celebrado elecciones? ¿En qué situación se
encuentra hoy Libia? ¿Quién maneja el cotarro?
Pues mucho ojo, porque puede que el
futuro no sea tan distinto al pasado.
T2 (¿UN NUEVO CAUDILLO?)
La segunda guerra civil produjo
un sinfín de líderes, donde destacan varios
civiles, como Aref Ali Nayed, exembajador
libio ante Emiratos árabes Unidos, o el mismo
Abdul Hamid Dbeibeh, el actual primer ministro.
Sin embargo, los pesos pesados de momento
siguen concentrados en nombres que nos
remiten al pasado y no al futuro.
Por ejemplo, podemos encontrar a
nada más y nada menos que a Saif al-Islam
Gaddafi ¿Os suena el apellido? Exacto,
es el mismísimo de Muammar Gaddafi, que en
noviembre de 2021 anuncio su pretensión de
participar en los comicios presidenciales. El
primogénito del dictador libio ha sido, desde
el derrocamiento de su padre, una especie de ficha
de puzzle en las negociaciones entre las distintas
facciones que se disputan el control del país.
(Saif al-Islam Gaddafi quedó en manos de la
milicia de Zintán, que operaba en el noroeste de
Libia, y que de alguna manera no tenía un bando
fijo en la segunda guerra civil. En cualquier
caso, la Cámara de Representantes de Libia
consideró otorgarle una amnistía, como parte del
proceso de pacificación, pero el resto de los
actores políticos libios rechazaron era opción.
Sin embargo, finalmente, en 2017 fue liberado,
y desde entonces su paradero es un enigma.
Apareció en 2021 en una ciudad del sur de Libia
para anunciar su candidatura a la presidencia,
pese a que sobre él pesa una pena de muerte
impuesta por tribunales de Trípoli, y una orden
de captura emitida por la mismísima Corte Penal
Internacional… Pero así es la Libia actual.)
Luego, en el polo opuesto, tenemos a Jalifa
Belqasim Hafter Alferjani, un viejo
conocido en la política libia.
Coronel de ejército, fue encarcelado y
enviado al exilio por el mismísimo Gadafi
después de tener un mal resultado contra
de facciones rebeldes chadianas durante
un conflicto en la frontera en los años 80.
Claro que en 2011 Hafter vio su oportunidad
y regreso al país como un flamante señor de la
guerra. En 2014, cuando estalló la segunda guerra
civil, condujo al Ejército Nacional Libio bajo la
autoridad de la Cámara de Representante electa y
no reconocida por el gobierno de Trípoli.
Hafter es un declarado crítico contra el
actual gobierno del Acuerdo Nacional.
N4 (23 de enero de 2020: Khalifa Haftar,
el señor de la guerra libio no está interesado en
llegar a un compromiso . Famosamente cascarrabias,
el señor de la guerra de 76 años no parece
interesado en llegar a un acuerdo. Lanzó una
ofensiva para capturar Trípoli en abril, horas
después de que el secretario general de la ONU,
Antonio Guterres, aterrizara en la capital para
preparar una conferencia de paz. Economist)
Las tropas de Hafter pasaron olímpicamente del
proceso de paz hasta que se vieron obligadas
a bajar las armas tras el alto el fuego
nacional de 2020. Pese a ello no parece
particularmente comprometido con ninguna
transición democrática y muchos le ven como
uno de los grandes obstáculos en ese camino.
De todas formas, no todas son malas noticias.
Desde marzo de este 2023 opera un
mecanismo denominado 6+6, donde 6
miembros de la Cámara de Representantes
libia y 6 miembros del Alto Consejo de
Estado del gobierno negocian las bases y las
condiciones para poder celebrar elecciones.
La postulación de Saif al-Islam Gaddafi
está -de momento- anulada, ya que en el
proceso electoral no podría participar
sujetos condenados por la justicia. E,
incluso, Haftar, pese a todo, parece
estar dando su brazo a torcer.
(El enviado de la ONU y Haftar coinciden
en la necesidad de finalizar el
proyecto de ley electoral. AA)
C4 ("Me he reunido hoy en Bengasi
con el mariscal de campo Jalifa
Haftar. Hemos acordado la necesidad de
finalizar el proyecto de ley electoral
del comité 6+6 y crear las condiciones
propicias para unas elecciones nacionales
inclusivas en Libia". Abdoulaye
Bathily, enviado de la ONU a Libia)
Y así estaban cuando llegó un nuevo
desastre… Que ha vuelto a cambiar las cosas.
T3 (SACANDO TAJADA)
Durante las primeras semanas
de septiembre de 2023, la tormenta Daniel
provocó auténticos diluvios en los países
mediterráneos. En Libia este fenómeno provocó
el colapso de presas y el desborde de ríos.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en localidades
como Al Baida, al noreste del país,
en 24 horas cayó el equivalente a 18
meses de precipitaciones habituales.
Las inundaciones dejaron tras de si miles y
miles de muertos y desaparecidos y decenas
de miles de damnificados en un país que no
parece salir de una para meterse en otra peor.
Claro que donde muchos vieron una tragedia,
otros encontraron una oportunidad. Jalifa
Haftar aprovechó la ocasión para perfilarse
como el gestor del “rescate” del pueblo.
(Khalifa Haftar utilizará las inundaciones
de Libia para profundizar su control)
El hombre fuerte del este de Libia mantiene
un férreo control sobre la ayuda tras las
inundaciones. ​​El desastre que asoló Derna el
11 de septiembre ha atraído de nuevo la atención
internacional sobre Hafter y su llamado
Ejército Nacional Libio, una coalición
militar que controla con mano de hierro la mitad
oriental de la dividida nación norteafricana. )
Hoy los territorios controlados
por este señor de la guerra
funcionan como auténticas dictaduras
militares. Nada escapa a su control.
Quizás por eso, gobiernos como el
de Meloni en Italia ven en Haftar
como alguien capaz de estabilizar los
asuntos migratorios en el Mediterráneo,
pese a lo cual se le considera
un tipo distante con Occidente.
Y, ¿Sabéis qué? Justo aquí entra
también Moscú… El Kremlin sigue
muy cerca la situación libia por
una razón muy concreta: el gas.
Libia, amigos, no solo tiene petróleo, también
tiene gas. De hecho, está entre las 20° mayores
reservas de gas natural de todo el mundo.
Sin embargo, las exportaciones de gas no
han podido recuperarse ni siquiera a un 50% de
los niveles previos al derrocamiento de Gadafi.
Por eso, una nueva Libia estable y aliada
a Bruselas representaría un nuevo socio
energético que ayude a satisfacer
la demanda europea de gas. Algo que,
por supuesto, no le interesa nada
a la Rusia de Vladímir Putin.
Esto es lo que empuja a
Rusia a respaldar a Haftar,
mientras que EE. UU. y varias naciones
europeas sostienen, mediante la ONU,
el apoyo al gobierno de Acuerdo
Nacional y su búsqueda de elecciones.
(El hombre fuerte del este de Libia,
Haftar, se reúne con Putin en Moscú.)
Eso sí, ya sabéis que la política es política.
Así que ya se están produciendo contactos entre
Washington y Haftar para no llevarse ningún
mal susto en el corto plazo. Y de hecho,
en el pasado, el propio Jalifa Haftar trabajó
con la CIA hasta el punto de llegar a
obtener la ciudadanía norteamericana.
Ahora este viejo señor de la guerra parece estar
diciendo que podría transigir con las elecciones
si se asegura que uno de sus hijos pueda
postularse. La política familiar, un clásico.
Queridos, amigos, amigas, los últimos doce
años han sido muy duros para los libios. De
toda aquella primavera árabe llena de idealismo
democrático, hoy queda poco y nada. El fracaso
del diseño de la transición y el creciente
papel de un caudillo militar que promete
orden a cambio de libertad, no augura el
mejor de los horizontes para este país.
Estaremos atentos. Pero por ahora, turno para ti:
¿Fue peor el remedio que la enfermedad para
los libios? ¿Crees que con Gadafi les hubiera
ido mejor? ¿Qué futuro ves para este país?
Déjanos tú respuestas en los comentarios.
Y ahora, si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante, no olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a VisualPolitik si es que no lo
has hecho ya. Un saludo y hasta la próxima.